qu'est-ce que je fais ici, allons-y,
je vais y réfléchir
oh je me suis senti mieux, mais
ça me fait honte que tu rencontres des filles tout le
temps ouais
parce que toute douleur celle-ci est différente en
pensant que
je viens d'un monde si différent  sûrement que
nous commençons je n'ai jamais ressenti ça pour
quelqu'un
m'aurais-tu encore debout maintenant ce que j'ai
déjà fait quelque chose comme ça avant de
voir que ce que je viens juste de déposer
ça obtiendrais-tu ça de ta voiture je
n'ai pas  j'ai pu les lire pendant des
années tu veux que je te les lise
le 10 avril et j'ai oublié la voiture le
visage de foin brûlant
ma très chère Ruth je me souviens de cette robe que
tu portais même quand j'ai oublié en mon propre
nom j'aimerais pouvoir prendre  un peu tous être
heureux pour toujours
après tout le monde ne comprend pas ce que
tu as fait
était aussi simple
quand
Luke tu dois arrêter ou la prochaine fois
tu iras plus probablement le chercher à
la morgue c'est ma vie c'est tout ce
que je sais que je ne peux pas être  avec quelqu'un si à chaque
fois qu'ils franchissent la porte je ne sais pas
si je vais voir  Je les reviens Hannes ne reviendra jamais
Je devrais toujours faire ce travail L'
amour demande des sacrifices
mais ça vaut le coup